it was fun to see what the Avengers
premiere what does it like to be part of
that Marvel families it's so fun to get
to be part of that that universe and I'm
very excited for the film to come out
your first we day it's a big deal
what inspired you to be here well I was
lucky enough to travel to Kenya with the
weak foundation several years ago and
was just so impressed by the work they
do on the ground building schools
creating these real ways of helping the
entire community not just the kids who
go to school but also their entire
family is with building wells and
microfinance for the parents and just
really adopting the the entire community
and and was so moved by how they were
able to make change that way and then to
see the work that they do here both in
the US and Canada in Japan with students
who are wanting to make change and in
empowering them and giving them voice
and rewarding them and making it like a
cultural movement that this generation
is going to be socially active and is
going to Karen is going to make change
and I'm just very inspired by all the
young people who are here today
[Music]
[Applause]